There's another
vector operation,
which we call the vector product
and sometimes this operation
is called the cross product.
And this is taking two vectors
A, the operation cross,
B. And this will
give a new vector C.
And now we want to
define that new vector C.
So let's draw a
three dimensional
picture where we have a plane.
And on this plane, we
have two vectors A and B.
And those vectors are forming
an angle theta between them.
Now a plane defines
two unit normals.
I'll draw one up,
which I'm going
to call n hat right hand rule.
And the reason for
that right-hand rule
is if we take A cross B,
then our right hand thumb
is pointing in the perpendicular
direction to the plane.
Now I could have chosen
a unit vector down,
n hat left-hand rule.
And this would correspond
to taking my left hand
and having A cross
B pointing down.
So the way we're going to
define our cross-product
is with the right-hand rule.
And so we define it like this.
That the vector C has
magnitude, the magnitude
of A times sine of theta,
the magnitude of B,
and its direction is given
by the right-hand rule.
Now one of the reasons
for this definition
is let's draw a vector
A and a vector B.
When you have two vectors,
they define a magnitude
in the following way.
That we can think
about any two vectors
define an area of
a parallelogram.
And we can define
that area as follows.
Let's drop a perpendicular.
And let's call this B perp.
Then the area, which
is a positive quantity,
is given by-- and by
the way, our angle theta
here will be always
positive-- so we're
going to make it 0 theta pi.
And that way sine of theta is
always a positive quantity.
The area is the height, so
that B perp times the base,
which is the magnitude of A,
and so we can write that as A,
and the magnitude of B
perp is B sine theta.
So this quantity, B sine
theta, is precisely what's
occurring there.
So the magnitude of C is
equal to the area formed
by the vectors A
and B. And we have
a choice of which way we
want to pick C to point.
And that's where,
as a convention,
we're choosing the
right-hand rule.
Now again, there
is a symmetry here
in that I can also define
the area of that triangle
in the following way.
Let's write this, theta.
Instead of taking
how much of B is
perpendicular to
the direction of A,
let's drop the
perpendicular this way,
and write that as a perp.
And then the same
area can be expressed
as the magnitude of--
well, we'll express it
as A perp times B. And
A perp is the magnitude
of A sine theta times
the magnitude of B.
And that's our same
definition as before.
And so you see, a sine theta
is appearing over here.
So in either choice,
our vector operation
says take any two vectors.
Any two vectors forms
a parallelogram.
The area of that
parallelogram is the magnitude
of the vector product.
And the direction
of this new vector C
is given by the right-hand
rule with respect
to that parallelogram
in that sense.